what's happened to the communities who
lived near the Trinity test did any
Manhattan Project scientists have a
long-term health problems and how did
the father of the bomb really die these
are a few of the disturbing questions
that Oppenheimer doesn't answer some
spoilers ahead for Oppenheimer
the most obvious exclusion in
Oppenheimer is any actual depiction of
the atomic bombs dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki but if you think about it
for even a minute you'll likely come to
understand why Nolan and his team update
to keep these events off screen the mass
murder of innocent civilians perpetuated
by the United States in Japan is
sickening and the film treats it with
the gravity required however going so
far as to show the bombings may not have
accomplished much Beyond shock value
threading the line between honest
depiction and gratuitous dramatizing is
tough Nolan clearly decided it wasn't
something he wanted to tackle in this
film so instead of crafting a
controversial reenactment he chose to
convey the effect of the bombings in
other ways you are the man who gave them
the power to destroy themselves
and the world is not prepared
Gene tatlock with whom up and Heimer has
a long-standing affair plays a
relatively small but incredibly
important Walden Oppenheimer Gene's
suicide is a major moment in the story
giving the physicist a glimpse of what
it's like to feel responsible for
innocent death what the film doesn't get
into is that tatlock's death has been
the subject of some big conspiracy
theories according to the book an atomic
Love Story the extraordinary women in
Robert oppenheimer's life taluk's
autopsy found traces of chlorohydrate in
her body a compound often used at the
time in combination with alcohol to
render a person unconscious other
circumstances surrounding her death such
as the non-fatal dose of barbiturates in
a system and the fact that her suicide
note was left unsigned have led some to
question whether or not statlock may
have actually been killed Nolan slightly
references a conspiracy theory that Gene
was murdered with a short flashback
scene in its Oppenheimer scenes of black
left hand putting her head into the
bathtub however the film doesn't
explicitly say that people thought she
was murdered of course none of these
series have ever been proven but they
are an interesting piece of the story
that Oppenheimer leaves out
unless you're a World War II history
buff you might not have even noticed
that girdle appears briefly in
Oppenheimer a famous logician girdle is
in the scene where Oppenheimer consults
Albert Einstein in the woods about the
dangers of an atomic detonation Einstein
remarks that his friend girdle who was
forced to flee Nazi occupation in
Austria is still terrified that German
spies will try to poison or assassinate
him in America this was true of the real
girdle as well to try to assuage his
fear and paranoia he had his wife
prepare or taste most of his meals after
she was hospitalized from a stroke in
the late 1970s however girdle's wife was
unable to fulfill these duties as a
result a girdle effectively starved
himself he died from this
self-starvation and malnutrition in 1978
with his wife osmily outliving him well
girdle's Grim story would have been a
bit of a tungent in Oppenheimer it shows
just how powerful the Nazi machine of
fear and violence was even when he was
safe on the other side of the world and
decades after the death of Adolf Hitler
the esteemed logician couldn't escape
the scars of the Nazi regime had
inflicted on him
the Los Alamos facility depicted in
Oppenheimer was intentionally
constructed in a remote area of New
Mexico however that didn't stop the
Fallout from the Trinity test from
leaking out into the surrounding areas
of the state because the U.S government
was determined to maintain absolute
secrecy for the Manhattan Project no
nearby ranchers or residents were warned
of what was coming boom that thing
exploded I mean it was a big explode it
wasn't like the regular one we'd been
hearing the explosion from Trinity was
visible for miles around but in the wake
of the test the government claimed it
was simply an ammunition accident the
reality is much darker of course
radiation from the test seeped into food
and water supplies and neighboring
communities leading to Serious medical
problems for residents however because
of the secrecy surrounding the project
and the reluctance of government
officials to take accountability the
so-called Trinity Downwinders struggled
for decades to acquire adequate
compensation heart disease and various
forms of cancer became highly prevalent
in these areas as a result of the test
killing locals who had no way preparing
themselves frequently forgotten in
larger discussions of the Manhattan
Project the Trinity Downwinders are yet
another group of Innocents whose lives
were irrevocably Changed by America's
insistence on a nuclear weapons program
Boris Pash is one of the more villainous
key characters in Oppenheimer he's an
intelligence officer determined to root
out any semblance of communist activity
surrounding the Manhattan Project in one
scene General Leslie Groves warns
Oppenheimer that Pash is downright
vicious in his hatred of Communism and
that it previously suggested highly
immoral forms of interrogation including
off the book's torture and executions
bash's activity during World War II is
represented pretty accurately in the
film but his activities after the end of
the war May well have involved some of
the things gross mentions in the movie
from 1949 to 1952 Pash worked for the
CIA specifically as a head of program
Branch 7 or pb7 for short the official
purpose of pb7 was vague as it served as
a catch-all for any Espionage or
counterintelligence duties not directly
assigned to other branches according to
an official U.S Senate report from 1976
the group may have also been responsible
for potential assassination and
kidnapping operations though patch
tonight this kind of work being done
under his jurisdiction his deputy chief
claimed the contrary to stating that pb7
was directly responsible for
assassinations and kidnappings according
to the Senate report this study backs up
the film's portrayal of Posh as a brutal
man with very few moral limits if you
reach the end of Oppenheimer thinking
how miraculous it is that no Manhattan
Project scientists died of radiation
poisoning well we've got some bad news
for you Oppenheimer is full of small
details from the real history but it
leaves out several gruesome instances of
how dangerous building the bomb really
was according to the U.S department of
Energy's official Manhattan Project
archive several workers were exposed to
intense radiation while working with the
uranium though none died in an ironic
twist of fate the Project's first
radiation fatality came after the end of
the war when Harry K dolly in dropped
some materials and ended up dying weeks
later in 1946 another death came to the
still operating facility when physicist
Louis slotin also dropped fictional
materials and received a heavy dose of
radiation these instances may have been
emitted from the film simply because the
most fatal ones took place after the war
however they still speak to the dangers
of working with nuclear materials and
the inherent risk of being the first
people ever to experiment with such
technology
Werner Heisenberg only appears in one
scene in Oppenheimer years before the
rise of Hitler's Nazi regime in Germany
Oppenheimer meets him during his
training in Europe and were later told
how he winds up leading Germany's own
Atomic weapons program like many other
German scientists from World War II
Heisenberg avoided consequences for its
contributions to the Nazi war machine he
went on to hold a number of prestigious
scientific positions after the war in
his later years Heisenberg claimed that
he helped Drive German research and
development away from weapons
specifically as he objected morally to
the use of an atomic bomb in more recent
times some historians and journalists
have claimed that Heisenberg even helped
leak information about secret Nazi
research to the Allied Powers how true
all of these claims are has been a
subject of extensive debate for years
but there's an undercurrent to them that
gets more uncomfortable the more you
look at it Heisenberg is the kind of
person that history wants to exonerate
it would be much cleaner if we could
just focus on his Nobel Prize years and
remember him as a Trailblazer in the
field of quantum physics the problem is
that there's a whole campaign of Nazi
Conquest oppression and genocide in
there too Oppenheimer doesn't spend much
time on this part of Heisenberg's life
which makes sense given his relatively
minor role but it's still a messy part
of the history that's well worth
reiterating
Oppenheimer briefly mentions that the
area of and around Los Alamos was sacred
ancestral land for local Native American
tribes after the end of the war
Oppenheimer recommended that President
Harry S Truman give the land back to its
original indigenous inhabitants of
course by that time the whole area was
already changed Beyond repair because of
both the government facilities
constructed there and the Fallout from
the Trinity test while salamos was home
to a number of Pueblo communities prior
to the Manhattan Project the
construction of the government facility
disrupted a long history in the area
preventing traditional patterns of
hunting fishing and various other rides
indigenous art and pottery became such a
popular farm with the Los Alamos
scientists and their families that it
fractured the very economy and ecosystem
of the Pueblo tribes in addition a
number of Hispanic homesteaders in the
area were essentially pushed off their
land by the US government they were
given no real choice and received far
less financial compensation for their
acreage than their white counterparts
today Los Alamos remains forever changed
by these colors Imperial actions
you think that in the case of the
Manhattan Project beating the Nazis
would be far more important to the US
government than the personal lives of
individual scientists
before the Nazis done but this is the
1940s we're talking about so you'd be
wrong recently the classified documents
show that communism wasn't the only red
flag intelligence officials were looking
for at Lars Alamos the FBI also spends
immense resources monitoring and
investigating those workers suspected of
being gay houses and facilities for the
Manhattan Project were bugged and the
behavior of workers was constantly being
evaluated a group of women known as a
Manhattan 8 received particular
attention for being suspected lesbians
which later led to the revocation of
security clearances President Eisenhower
officially outlawed gay individuals from
serving in federal positions in 1953
with queerness widely seen as subversive
and frequently paralleled with other
anti-American groups like Communists
given their socio-political climate of
the time this information probably isn't
surprising to anyone but it does show
just how invasive the FBI was during
this era For Better or Worse working on
the Manhattan Project was seen by many
as a huge Service to America however
anyone suspected of queer activity which
did Morris enemies the National Heroes
though the film carries his name it
doesn't follow Oppenheimer all the way
to the end of his life we get a brief
glimpse of his final years enough Flash
Forward and shows him being awarded the
Enrico Fermi award in 1963 but the film
doesn't show how Oppenheimer died in
reality he passed away shortly after
that prestigious moment succumbing to
lung cancer on February 18 1967 it was
only 62 years old now I am become deaf
the destroyer of worlds Oppenheimer was
a heavy smoker as depicted in the film
by the pipe he always seems to be
carrying and what could be seen as an
ironic twist he received radiation
treatment for his condition seeking
healing from the very thing he used to
create a weapon of mass destruction
regardless the treatment was
unsuccessful and Oppenheimer passed away
the next year in a dramatized version of
his life like Nolan's film there's
something interesting about
oppenheimer's premature relatively an
eventful death but looked at as part of
the larger history perhaps it's not
important enough to include in a movie